my
challenge in our generation is that
gradually through entertainment through
television through media through every
way possible we are living in a
generation of the
dumbing down of ideas
because we have traded effectiveness
for busyness statistics say
yeah somebody ought to clap on that
[Applause]
[Music]
we are busier than any other generation
we have seen in the last three to four
hundred years
we are so busy we are we are busier than
a wall within a one-armed wallpaper
hangar we're just busy
you'll get it later don't worry about it
it'll hit you in a minute we are just
as busy as we can be and we think
because we're busy
we're effective but i want you to
challenge your schedule for a minute
and ask yourself are you are you really
being effective or is your life
cluttered with
all kinds of stuff that demands you and
drains you
and taxes you and stops you from being
your highest
and best self and are you substituting
busyness and all the chaos that goes
along with business
from being effective let me tell you a
bunch of scientists got together they
begin to do some research
and they begin to determine that 80 of
the things
we do are busy things that we do in an
area that is not effective that the
average person only spends
20 percent of their time doing the thing
that they are really
gifted at created at passionate about
excited to do and the rest of it is all
the
dismal dumb stuff that we all have to do
in order to survive
just crazy stuff that we're doing wonder
what would happen
if we would go from doing 80 of things
that are busy but not effective
and 20 of the things that are really
effective if we would
switch those numbers around and only
give 20
of our time to the things that we have
to do and 80 percent of our time
to the thing that we were created to do
wonder what would happen to your life
now think about it a minute i
there's a lot of things you could take
from me and i could make it you could
take my suit
i got another one you could take my car
i could get another one you could take
my house
i could get another house but when you
take my
time you have taken something from me
that is totally irreplaceable we take
all kind of classes for money management
we we know how to manage our money we
know how to repair our houses
we're working on our hair and our bodies
and all of this kind of stuff
we do everything except the most
important thing is to value
our time it takes
time to be creative you were
meant to be creative you were created in
the likeness and the image of a creator
and in that likeness and in that image
you have
creativity if you had time
you would be creative but in the absence
of time
and with busyness and cluttering people
the phone baby
you all got music playing on your phone
all kinds of stuff and no matter what
kind of song you put on after a while
you hate to hear it
because every time you hear that sound
you know it somebody else
wants something else from you that's
taking you away
from what you are gifted and creative to
do i
am afraid that too many times
we have spent so much focus on teaching
you to be good seed
that we haven't taught you the power of
good soil
and so when we come to soil issues
the seed ignores the soil
we flick the channel that has nothing to
do with me
we close our eyes because we have been
taught to be
good seed but we have not been taught to
pay attention
to soil and yet the bible is clear jesus
says
the sword went forth sowing seed and
some fell by the wayside some fell
amongst rocks some fell among stores
the whole text is about environment
look at you and look at your
environment
have you been positioned to flourish
[Music]
positioning has a lot to do with
flourishing
to be in an environment in a family that
supports you my sister and i were
talking the other day
i was telling her what an amazing person
she is that all of our lives together
and and all the things that god did in
my life not once
in all of the years that i've known her
and she was there when mama had me
have i ever known her to be jealous of
me
not once not ever she has always been my
cheerleader and my greatest fan
and she said how can i be jealous of you
you're my brother i said a lot of people
have siblings that hate them that are
jealous of them that hope they choke
and some of my development has to be
that god
planted me in an environment of people
that supported me my brother my sister
my mother my father they all
supported me you can have good seed
but if you've been in bad soil
people who hated you environments that
denied you
education that underserved you
communities that limited you
mentalities that poisoned you
[Applause]
until you hear what i'm saying if if
your
soil wasn't right it doesn't mean that
you're not right
but if your soil wasn't right it's going
to affect how you root
and how you grow and you might grow a
little bit
the bible says you can grow for a while
but then the
thorns will choke you out or the rocks
will not have enough soil
for your roots to grow are you blaming
god
for something you ought to be blaming
the soil for
you cannot take a peach seed
and plant it in a teaspoon of dirt
and expect it to grow though the
teaspoon of the dirt is the same size as
the peach seed
it will not grow the seed will only grow
when it is planted in something bigger
than itself
and i want to know where are you planted
this morning
are you planted in something bigger than
you
or have you always been planted in
teacups
surrounded by little dirt little
resources
small-minded people narrow limited
places
that never let you stretch to reach your
capacity
sometimes you gotta go where the corn is
listen listen clearly i want to
pronounce
a benediction on every
grieving weeping depressed
lonely frustrated tired spirit
your period of mourning is over
touch your girlfriend your sister girl
your cousin or me mo
and tell her i cried my last tear
yesterday
yesterday i cried my last tear yesterday
i cried my last tear yesterday
i cried my last tear yesterday
i cried my last tear yesterday
you can send them flowers back you can
give that sympathy card back
you can stop looking at me all pitiful
you can stop
seeing me as charity i got my strength
back
i got my fight back i got my drive back
i got my focus back glory to god
i'm forgetting those things which are
behind and
reaching to those things which are
before i got some press down in me
yeah yeah shake your sister girl so i
got some press in me
that's how i got in here tonight i got
some press down in me
that's why i'm watching on television i
got some press down in me
i got some fight in me if you don't
believe i got some press
in me look back in my history and ask
the folk who
fought me ask the people who said
i would never make it i got some press
in me i made it without them
i made it in spite of it i've seen
people who were on their grind
i've seen steve hurries on his grind
i've seen people on the ground what on
the grind really is
is a work ethic that would blow your
mind
it would blow your mind i'm 60 years old
and
everybody who works for me is younger
than me and they'll tell you i'll work
you up under the table
i'll work you up under the table where
does that come from
my father my father absolutely my father
is rigged
my let me tell you this chair is about
to break
my father's sitting here and my mother
is sitting here and they're fighting for
the mic from moment to moment my
grandmother talks to you every now and
then all of my ancestors
are sitting on this table all the way
back to nigeria
all of them
my ancestors were ebos from nigeria
and evos are called black jews that
they're industrious that they
go after things that they're hard
working people so all the way back in my
dna
we were self-sufficient and all of them
are sitting
here folks who name i can't even call
so what we're talking about is culture
okay
and not not racial culture family
culture
where where the demonstration of what my
father decided what grinding was
you weren't grinding till daddy said you
were grounded gotcha
take your hands out your pocket boy like
you got a million dollars in your pocket
they trained us
not to be lazy they talked about lazy
like it was a disease
do you have the courage to act
outwardly on what you see inwardly
or will you die a dreamer will you die
on the verge and on the edge
and on in the land of cutter water and
sugar
the strong hand rules the roost
do you have the courage i'm going to
drop something on you
it takes courage to be successful
[Applause]
it is far easier not to be successful
misery will always have company
success breeds contempt
if you don't want to make waves be
mediocre
be normal and fit in and if you're more
concerned about people
than you are god then neutralize
everything he put in you
just fit in with everybody else dress
like them
walk like them act like them eat like
them go where they go
think like they think do what they do
and once you neutralize your uniqueness
you don't need courage it takes courage
to be different
it takes courage to go where you've
never gone before
for some of you it took courage to come
to this conference
it takes courage to get you outside of
the bar it takes
courage to be successful it takes
courage to win
people don't talk about people that
don't win if you win they're going to
talk about you
do you have the courage to stand there
though the storms keep raising and the
people get to talking
and you stand there and say i've come
too far to turn around
that's your girlfriend and say do you
have the carriage
i'm gonna i'm gonna say something to you
[Applause]
it takes courage to be exceptional
it takes courage to be wise it takes
courage to be rich
it takes courage to be educated it takes
courage to be knowledgeable
because the moment you do it you don't
talk like you oh you got forgot where
you came from
look at you it takes courage
and i'm just wondering in this weak
watered down
mediocre society that we live in today
in this reality tv world we live in
today
i'm wondering if there's anybody left
that's got the courage
to say after all i've been through and
all my ancestors have been through
and all my parents have been through i
didn't come through all of that
just to fit in with normalcy i have the
courage
to go after my dream what is something
you'd suggest
to add to our daily routine to empower
ourselves
quiet quiet we're too busy
we are so busy that we don't notice that
we're not productive
busy does not mean that you you are
producing if we are just spinning our
wheels
and and the great thinking and progress
that we've made in this country
steam engines telephones uh automobiles
uh all types of things uh spacecrafts
were done by people who had moments to
think
we're moving so fast at breakneck speed
and if we get a free moment we're on
twitter and facebook and everything
it's the death of creativity and i would
challenge people
to to go back to meditation and and if
your spiritual go back to prayer
if you're not just go back to just
laying still for a moment to clear your
head
to hit the reset button because we are
starting every day
with the burdens from yesterday
assaulting us
in today let's put a comma between all
of this i read somewhere as an actor i
think
said it that once a week he doesn't talk
[Music]
doesn't talk all day yeah just peace
yeah yeah just be
shut it all down and you'd be surprised
what you can hear
when you shut up the very first command
god says to adam is to be fruitful
you can only be fruitful if you are
seedful
okay so we're talking about the
difference between fruit and seed
identifying your seed is what causes you
to be fruitful
the first revelation of seed should
happen
in your family you should have parents
who are looking at their kids
looking for seeds i'm gonna give you my
grandbaby story you asked for it you're
gonna get it you're just gonna get it
so we're in my church and it's dark and
my grandbabies in there and a bunch of
friends are in there and we're taking
pictures and i can't find the light
and you know the lights are complicated
and i can't figure out how to turn all
this stuff
in and so we're trying to get some
pictures and so my grandbaby ran
and she says wait a minute paul i'm
going to get
a flashlight she went up under the pew
where we have hidden flashlights
snatch down a flashlight and brought it
over and said now take the picture
and so i said to her i said baby don't
you want to be
kinsey don't you want to be in the
picture she said no i don't want to be
in the picture i want to hold the light
that's the seed right there that's the
seed right there
so we came back to the house and i was
getting ready to take a picture
and i'm trying to keep up with you
millennials you know it's so hard
and i was trying to take a selfie and i
was trying to i got a timer you know
where you can back up nickel
you know
if you follow me on instagram you know
this is true and
uh and so i couldn't get my phone to sit
up
and she she wouldn't got some books and
propped it up and i said i told
my daughter i said put her in leadership
classes put her in management classes
she's a problem solver
that starts early early early
her instinct in the situation is to
solve the problem
she says i don't want to be in the
picture i want to hold the light those
are seeds
okay directing that child toward an area
where you can
cultivate what god has planted down
inside of them is important
it's very very important
there are people in this room that have
dormant seeds laying inside of them
that if they get in the right atmosphere
they're going to turn into things you
have never
seen before they didn't always have the
benefit of parents who could see it or
had time to see it or knew how to see it
but even as adults there are still seeds
down in you that have not been
touched yet that's what happened to
elisha
he was fulfilling his parents vision
plowing in the field that boy wasn't no
farmer
just because you can run a plow doesn't
mean you're a farmer
but sometimes we get stuck in what
people expect
right and we never find out who we are
because we're living somebody else's
dream
and so there he is plowing in the field
doing what his daddy wanted going around
and said i guess this is all life has
for me and he's going around
and around the circle like many people
are listening to me right now you go to
work go to church go home go to work go
to church
go home go to work go to church go home
you're planning around around the circle
until elijah passed by him and then he
was exposed
to some the moment he was exposed to
something greater he dropped something
lesser
be strong and very courageous
be strong and very courageous
be strong and be of good courage
be strong and possess the land
because god knows that for what you're
going to do
it is not by our strength
you understand you understand she helped
me preach this thing this morning girl
it's inner strength so my fourth point
is you got to have inner strength for
this fight
it's not your outer strength it's not by
might
nor by power but by my spirit saith the
lord
so you got to have that inner that inner
that inner that cut strength and
belly strength that devil defined
come hell or high water strength that
rolled me out in front of them and i'll
preach from a chair strength
that tenacity to take a licking and keep
on
taking that inner strength that well i
can't do as i would
i'm gonna do as i can but i'm not gonna
stop doing
to the best of my ability i'm gonna
stretch
strong strong
strong strong strong
if you didn't get a good job you have to
create a good job
come on yeah you have to create a job
yeah
[Applause]
you have to carve out a niche in the
earth for yourself
and be creative you must realize that we
were created
by a creator who created us in his
likeness and in his image and if our
creator
is a creator then i have to be creative
somewhere down inside of every single
solitary person
in this room is creativity whether you
tap into it or not
we were not meant to follow a marching
band and follow it behind other people's
creativity
and not discover our own you
have creativity you have passion and you
have purpose
and giving people the freedom and the
wherewithal to
to build that i suddenly realized when i
sat down to write this book that
everything i ever experienced i had to
build from the ground up
i never inherited anything i mean my
father gave me a watch
and and i appreciate it and uh
you know my parents weren't so much into
what they left to you but they were
masterful at what they left in you
the stuff you've been through don't pay
it any attention
it is just a sign that the baby is
coming
you're on the verge of birthing you're
on the verge of birthing
you're on the verge of birthing you're
about to give birth
i want you to touch everybody you can
reach and tell them the baby is coming
the baby is coming
the baby is coming the baby is coming
the baby is coming
the baby is coming the baby is coming
the baby is coming
you don't want to leave me now the baby
is coming you don't want to walk out on
me now the baby is coming
i haven't had my best idea yet i haven't
had my most creative moment yet
i haven't produced my dream yet i don't
care whether you're 30 40 50
60 70. there's something down inside of
you that's still
kicking inside of you that wants to get
out and it wants to live
it wants to live the whole reason you're
here today
is because there's something in you that
needs to be fed
that needs to be stirred that needs to
be electrified
that needs to be illuminated there's
something
down inside you cry let me
[Applause]
on your yes to break and for you to give
birth to the greatest
idea you have ever had
make some noise
anybody who left you is going to miss it
they're going to miss it they're going
to miss the greatest part of you
the greatest part of your destiny the
greatest part of your creativity
it took everything you went through
yesterday to get you ready for what you
are about to do today
you are standing on the verge of a great
awakening
or you wouldn't be here if i'm talking
to you make some noise in this place
i can't hear you
i believe there are businesses in you
companies in you
concepts in you books to be written
paintings to be drawn concepts to be
birthed
ideas creative concepts there's
something
that you could do that you could think
in your life that would radically change
your life
somebody could take the hand you've been
dealt and
win with it same circumstances same
ideas
they would do it through what they
thought about your
life but we don't need somebody cause we
got you
we got you you're the one
you are the one i want you to join hands
with somebody for just a minute
i'm telling you right now if you are
going to
birth your dream
your calling your passion and the
second half of your life you can't draw
back when life gets tough
you've got to stand up to it and push
get that person by the hand because
there's something inside of them that is
about to happen
squeeze their hand
and when i count to three i want every
man and every woman that's got a concept
that's got an
idea i want you to push with all of your
might
until dreams and concepts and ideas
start to birth out of you in the middle
of the night you're gonna need
pens and pads by your bed tonight
because you're gonna have to get up in
the middle of the night and start
writing down all the stuff
that's gonna start coming out of your
spirit when this day is ready
are you ready one
two three
if you want to change your life in the
next 30 days for free check
out my training right here below or if
you want some more affirmations from
john
assaraf check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there